artists done Beach on Instagram has
given Batman fans a glimpse of what it
might look like to see the world's
greatest detective fused with a
stormtrooper from the Star Wars Galaxy
the AI generated artwork shows a Batman
and white stormtrooper armor walking
through downtown New York City that logo
emblazoned on his chest and a sleek
black cape around his neck holy
masquerade but the most interesting part
of the photo is the helmet combining the
futuristic Vents and accessories of the
classic Stormtrooper headpiece for the
Batman's pointed ears holy helmet this
design also moves a toothy mouth that
usually sits in the middle of the
stormtrooper helmet down and places it
along the very bottom of the face mask
someone's mirroring the design of the
much more intimidating helmet worn by
Darth Vader holy cliche by combining the
classic stormtrooper armor with Batman's
cape and Cal Beach's AI image presents a
futuristic version of The Dark Knight
who certainly wouldn't look out of place
in the Star Wars franchise one he would
be sure to strike fear into any
Intergalactic criminals who cross his
path